je suis très content de vous rencontrer
moi je suis un petit peu c'est plus
qu'une merde maintenant non
vous cherchez quoi madame le concert de
Renaud
la mer elle m'a pris je me souviens un
Martin
ça fait vraiment chier j'ai vraiment les
bouts parce que [__]
papa
expliqué parce que c'est trop fort aussi
tu penses que Bruel lui a piqué un peu
tous ses fans ça fait ça c'est
j'ai pas comprendre comment les gens
sont cons à côté ce genre de musique
Sims on s'en fout de Bruel
ah comme tu dis on s'en fout c'est moi
qui l'a pris
la chanson française
c'est que moi j'ai un chien et ça vous
lâche-moi pour le vérifier je sais pas
pour toi
vous lui dites parce que il est dans le
creux de la vague vous l'aimez beaucoup
et que vous allez acheter son prochain
album
ah mais non c'est pas vrai je vais pas
là
je sais pas trop je suis toujours pas
convaincu que vous êtes le vrai chanter
un peu pour voir
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
chante à vous de choisir ça alors là
c'est pas qui prend la mer c'est la mer
qui prend l'or ça vous rappelle quelque
chose vous avez une petite pièce pour
lui ah ben j'ai pas de porte monnaie sur
moi chaque une carte bleue il prend tout
je suis très content de vous rencontrer
mon chien tu peux lui dire c'est plus
qu'une merde maintenant
oui il y en a un seul demande si
j'entends français ou en étranger on
sait pas mais on comprend bien vous
voulez bien signer sa pétition contre le
réchauffement de la planète
aujourd'hui
vous êtes dur avec lui
et vous le faites travailler dur comme
ça tout le temps
[Musique]
si le roi des cons perd et son trône
il aurait 58 millions de prétendants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]